(instrumental music)
(rattle)
- Shit.
(exhales)
So I tried to schedule it earlier
but they had a cancellation
so if I didn't take that
then I wouldn't be able to
see my doctor for like a week.
- Okay, I understand.
I'm just wondering how
many of these appointments
there's gonna be.
Okay, if you're stressed out about class
maybe consider dropping something
taking a lighter course load.
- It's not about being
stressed out in class.
- Have you tried yoga?
I don't know.
- Doesn't work.
- Maybe you should try smoking weed.
- No, that just makes me more anxious.
- What about acupuncture?
(instrumental music)
- Barbara.
- I'm sorry Ms. Darragh
but we need your doctor
to authorize a refill.
- Yes, but Barbara you know
that I need my prescription.
Barbara, Babs, come on, we go back.
I'm here every 30 days,
sometimes sooner if I
have a yeast infection.
I have anxiety.
Okay, I have anxiety today,
I had anxiety yesterday,
I have no reason to believe
that I won't have anxiety tomorrow.
- If you get your doctor
to call in the refill--
- Barbara, can you not just
help me out on like principle?
Didn't you take an oath?
- [Voiceover] You'll need to come in
and see Dr. Graff Breaman
for a 20-minute appointment.
- Okay, can I come in today at lunch?
(laughs)
- No, the earliest appointment
is next week at two PM.
- Um, actually I'm out of pills though.
- Maybe schedule your
appointment in advance?
- I did actually but I had to cancel it
because I had a geology
exam and with geology
you have to be there in person because--
- [Voiceover] So do you
want the appointment?
- Sure.
- [Doctor] So it's working well?
- Yep.
- Any new side effects?
- It's just that last week
was a really tough week for me and--
- If you'd like I can
put you on another drug
that some others have
had some success with.
It's an anti-seizure drug.
- I don't have seizures.
- Yes, but another effect of the drug--
- Okay, but I still need
to come back in two months?
- Actually, I'd like
to see you in one month
if we put you on this.
(instrumental music
changes to dramatic music)
(beating)
- Oh God, One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
One, two, three,
(gasps)
one, two, three, four, five.
Yeah hi, I'm calling
to check up on a refill
for Darragh last name,
first name Kelsey with a K.
(beating and dramatic music)
1990.
45, you said 45 30 minutes ago.
(heavy breathing)
- It'll be 15 minutes.
(exhales)
(melancholy instrumental music)
Darragh!
That'll be a $600 copay.
- What?
- I'm sorry, did you want the generic?
- Obviously Barbara.
- Okay, that'll be 45 minutes.
(shuffling)
(heavy breathing)
(engine and beeping)
(techno music)
(rattle)
- Shit.
(techno music)
(digital tones)